- Wewahitchka High School is
a great little school here.
It's a rural area, about
350 kids, seven through 12.
A great school though,
our kids are interested
in bettering themselves.
Ms. Cameron Totman is a
reading ELA teacher here,
English Language Arts teacher.
Particularly what
impressed me about Cameron
is she wants to individualize
education for each student.
She's jumping on the LearnStorm
at the Kahn Academy as one of her tools.
- The activity that you guys
are gonna do next is talking
about the growth mind-set.
I was introduced to LearnStorm this year
by one of our math teachers
who was participating.
She thought that we would benefit
from the growth mindset content
and activities that came with LearnStorm.
- One thing that I learned from
the growth mindset activities is that
your intelligence can grow,
just like your muscles can grow.
And that's something
that really stuck with me
'cause I didn't know that before.
(upbeat music)
- This is my first year
actually using Kahn Academy
in a classroom and I've found
it extremely valuable tool.
I was teaching a class for students
who were trying to
improve their test score
on the SAT and ACT and
so we found some specific
lessons that worked really well with them.
Definitely the LearnStorm
portion of the program
was more enjoyable to students I think,
then just the regular skills
practice that they were doing.
They were motivated by seeing their daily
progress on that progress tracker.
(students cheering)
- LearnStorm really helps me
because it really helped me
realize that I had more
potential than I thought I did.
- LearnStorm made everything
fun, made learning fun.
LearnStorm helped me build more confidence
and believing in myself
that I can do this.
I don't really think I would have
got through high school without it.
- [Cameron] I think the biggest
impact that LearnStorm had
on my students this year
was for those students
who really took the time and engaged
in the self reflection activities.
They've learned the skill of goal setting.
They've learned things that are going
to affect them their whole lives
and they're going to be able
to keep going and keep growing.
- [Jay] The world is
going digital and we need
to start up finding good
digital resources in schools.
Kahn Academy has been the first one that
I felt like could be a significant,
a very significant part of a curriculum
here at Wewahitchka high school.
(upbeat music)